no
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
en esta emisión vamos a viajar a chile
para adentrarnos en uno de los episodios
más siniestros de la historia de este
país hablamos de colonia dignidad una
secta alemana que se instaló en esta
nación sudamericana en los años 60 y que
fue escenario de algunos de los hechos
más aberrantes de la historia cuyas
consecuencias siguen vigentes al día de
hoy y por eso nos acompañas a la luna a
garrido sobrevivientes de colonia
dignidad sal o luna muchísimas gracias
por tu presencia en france 24
santiago como estas gracias a ustedes
por supuesto por la invitación no por
favor gracias a ti nuevamente es algo
bueno si tuvieras que contarle a alguien
que desconoce estos hechos que
lamentablemente son muchas personas a lo
largo del mundo como le narrar tías que
es colonia dignidad quien fue paul
schaefer y cuál era la fachada de la
colonia pero que sucedía puertas adentro
son varias preguntas perdón pero que
están muy vinculadas entre sí
bueno sin ninguna uva para comenzar el
relato en relación a colonia y ni a la
primera palabra que utilizaría como para
que la gente pudiese dimensionar de
forma certera sería una sexta tal como
lo especifica en este caso el documental
una secta alemania y tal como tú dices
en la época del 60 se instala y llega a
la zona de parral hacia la cordillera
donde con una fachada de beneficiencia
comienza a
generar este estado dentro del mismo
estado chileno entregando salud
entregando también educación y
entregando trabajo que son prácticamente
pilares de una sociedad que pretende
surgir crecer y donde en chile en
aquella época se carecía de estas tres
bases principales y donde su líder
espiritual poliéster llega ya desde hyde
y alemania con denuncias de pedofilia y
abusos y violaciones y escapa en este
caso a chile
de cierto modo y no sé si amparado por
el gobierno alemán pero si este es este
país conocía de las haber nación spears
hfr comienza a ejecutar en alemania la
época del 60 y por supuesto su fachada
es al principio una sociedad benefactora
y educacional dignidad ese es el nombre
que es por el cual todo el mundo la
conoce sin embargo hacia adentro se
vivía un infierno verdad
claro precisamente el logra crear este
imperio porque finalmente fue un
verdadero imperio donde las normativas y
leyes que
dictaminaba eran prácticamente distintas
a lo que nosotros conocíamos como
chilenos estaban establecidas en la
constitución y efectivamente tal como el
documentario ha venido mostrando y así
una serie de otras investigaciones hubo
no solamente violaciones a menores
abusos a menores sino que también en la
época de la dictadura un gente que
desapareció hubo tráfico de armas hubo
también experimentos con las mitológicas
hoy en día colonia y necesitaba como una
organización criminal donde hubo nexos
que ellos estuvieron con en traficantes
de armas como dos mertens por ejemplo
que era alguien que le persiguió a nivel
internacional la verdad es que las
aristas y todos digamos las adversidades
que le unía o que en colonia en días se
cometieron son prácticamente pinceladas
que logramos ver generalmente en
documentales como netflix
en otros en los cuales algunos
periodistas comienzan a investigar
saludo contanos cómo llegaste voz a
colonia dignidad y también cómo era la
relación de scheffer contigo y con los
demás niños y niñas
mira la magia mi familia se atendía en
el hospital de colonia y niña no éramos
pacientes frecuentes sin embargo en el
85 nosotros sufrimos la pérdida de mi
hermana mayor erika que ella fue a tener
a mi sobrino que hoy en día ya es un
hombre al hospital público de sanitarios
en una negligencia médica ella tiene a
mi sobrino y en pocos minutos comienza a
sufrir una hemorragia donde los médicos
no la tienen a tiempo y mi hermana
finalmente fallece lo que de cierto modo
nos empuja o nos lleva a buscar una
atención
en cuanto a la medicina o el salud y
fuese distinta a mí también no quería
saber nada de nuevos hospitales digamos
chilenos y comenzamos a acercarnos apoyo
ni a iu ni a y en el 88 aproximadamente
se realizó una especie de estudio o
incautar para ver cómo reaccionaba la
juventud alemana
compartiendo con la cual tu chilena y en
esa época ingresó por primera vez a un
movimiento que era como scout pero en
aquel entonces fue solo por un día
después de un tiempo en el 91 92
aproximadamente ya se crea la jota de
pie o juventud vigila permanente que era
este movimiento de scouts donde los
jóvenes podíamos ir los fines de semana
y también las vacaciones y realizar un
sinnúmero de actividades que por
supuesto eran muy llamativas por ejemplo
la música el deporte el arte y también
se instruía mucho o se los entregaban
directrices en cuanto a la conducta que
nosotros como jóvenes teníamos que
llevar ese fue digamos el motor por el
cual entró a colonia y tal como también
aparece dentro del documental y también
lo ha señalado algunos cercanos al
chófer él desde el primer día en que me
ve en
creando una una especie de farol que les
obsesiona conmigo cuando yo tenía
aproximadamente 12 13 años
al extremo que al cabo de unos años él
le ofrece a mi familia a mi mamá poder
irnos a vivir al enclave alemán y sin
importar si nosotros necesitábamos una
caja de uno dos o tres pisos
prácticamente mi mamá podría elegirlo
todo esto y movido por esta obsesión
enfermiza en relación hacia mí
salvo un poco lo adelantadas previamente
pero contanos cuál era la relación entre
colonia dignidad y la dictadura de
pinochet qué error jugada en este
contexto colonia dignidad se han
encontrado fosas verdad sí así es bueno
sin ninguna agua el todo el período de
la dictadura dictadura militar tienen
nexos que son irrefutables e innegables
en relación al colonia ahí hubo
desaparición de gente hubo torturas
también pero de todas maneras amplió
quiero hacer súper enfático en algo que
es no politizar el tema del plugin y ahí
tampoco hoy que están en la palestra el
documental en netflix de algún partido
político intenté sacar ventajas ponerle
la responsabilidad es total vio
absolutamente transversal porque si bien
es cierto hay un período o un pasado
tremendamente oscuro y muy triste en
relación a la dictadura y colonia en ya
tenemos que también contextualizar y
darnos cuenta que hubo prácticamente 16
o 20 años de gobiernos democráticos sin
importar el color político opción
absolutamente nada hasta el día de hoy
no de hecho luego de la dictadura
continuó gozando de cierta impunidad se
lo contamos cuál fue el disparador para
que dijera basta bueno hasta aquí llegué
me escapó y como lo hiciste relata este
una noche en particular no que describe
es como una pesadilla en la que te le
plantea este ayer le dijiste incluso que
te daba asco que jugaste la vida y no
estaba solo verdad
mira el hubo un antes y un después y
esto evidentemente lo gatillo en este
caso todavía es miller todavía mejor
este joven que he llegado a los 10 años
a polonia ni a oriente también traía una
visión diferente del mundo sabía como en
el mundo real este este quebrantamiento
de voluntad o lavado de cerebros no
había surtido efecto y él es quien se
acerca a mí para abrirme ayuda de que
por favor le sacara que comienza a
contarme todas las atrocidades que se
comercian en colonia y hasta esa fecha
había sido había sufrió un intento de
abuso por parte del chef escribiendo lo
explica si estaba también en los
expedientes judiciales en mi caso fue
intento de abuso una violación porque
precisamente tuve en la fortaleza de
poder imponer me y no permitir que esto
ocurriera pero por supuesto el
gatillante fue todavía civiles y después
de muchos meses de intentar un trabajo
casi de doble agente es junto con la
peli junto con con algunos miembros del
poder judicial donde también me descubre
me descubre la gente de la gloria y me
da que no estoy reuniendo inventó toda
una historia cuando yo sé que me van a
delatar en colonia elía una chica que
iba en aquel entonces me voy tres días
antes a polonia
fingiendo que estaba enfermo en mi
colegio y habló con los dirigentes y le
digo que yo estoy intentando sacar la
información a la pda y para apoyo a la
colonia o sea imagínate la presión
psicológica sin embargo el que empuje
pasando me pidieron innumerables pruebas
en relación a tobías cartas fotografías
etcétera es más la fotografía que
aparece scheffer mirando un poco como
hacia el horizonte con una bufanda
fotografía las aquello de colonia y se
la entregué a la pedí para que tuvieran
imágenes más recientes sin embargo esto
nunca ocurrió a tus días está policía
jamás lo sacó del culo y porque
finalmente terminó obligándonos a que el
26 de julio cuando se realiza una
especie de acto con muchas personas
tomáramos la determinación de salir por
nuestros propios medios exponiéndonos
nuestras guías y también las de familia
sale o nos queda un minuto y medio más o
menos pero no quiero dejar de hacer de
la siguiente pregunta que es cómo se fue
gestando de alguna manera la caída de
jeffers si es que se puede hablar de una
caída verdad y cuál es hoy el estado de
las investigaciones
bueno sin ninguna duda
cuando yo salgo todavía es miller tal
como lo señala también sir hans ayunar
que es uno de los guardaespaldas que son
detenidos poner el chili point en la
hacienda la solitaria en argentina es y
otros señalan el día en que él ratifica
y se da cuenta de que todavía no había
sido secuestrado ni yo tampoco sino que
habíamos salido por nuestra propia
cuenta
él dice este es mi fin y scheffer es
obligado o él mismo se ve obligado a
escapar a argentina en el momento en que
empieza el hecatombe o el declive de la
imagen de porsche ese es precisamente el
26 de julio cuando por fortuna pude
ayudar a todavía es miller bien la
historia aunque muchas personas creen
que todo esto ya cesan job las víctimas
de colonia línea en especial los jóvenes
que fuimos abusados otro ahora que aún
en la época del 90 continuamos en una
lucha encarnecida y tremenda en contra
de los actuales gerentes de colonias en
ya que son los hijos de los antiguos
jerarcas y cómplices
ellos hasta el día de hoy continúan
obstaculizando que lo que determinó la
corte suprema en el 2013 llega a buen
puerto seguimos luchando a pesar de que
llevamos más de 20 años ya fallecido
incluso jóvenes esperando que se haga
justicia y todo eso por gobiernos y por
en este caso poderes judiciales casi o
inoperantes e incompetentes salud o luna
garrido muchísimas gracias por tu
presencia en la entrevista de france 24
se va luego se pasó volando este tiempo
santiago muchas gracias a usted y por
supuesto un saludo enorme a
france 24 agradeció normalmente por la
invitación no gracias a ti por favor a
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y también
en france 24 punto com sigan con
nosotros
y